ALLEN ARCHULETA ATKINS BATES
BACKER FORGES BRADFORD BY ADAM
CORTESE DALLY DODD TERRAZZO
EGGMAN GLAZER GONZALEZ ROVE
HERTZBERG HUESO HURTADO JONES
KAMLAGER. WHERE'D LEYVA LIMóN
MCGUIRE MELENDEZ IN NEWMAN
NIELSEN OCHO OF BOTH. PAN
PORTANTINO ROTH RUBIO SKINNER
STERN AMBERG WHITE HOUSE SKI
WIENER WILK. MEMBERS OF A
QUORUM IS PRESENT. WHAT THE
MEMBERS AND OUR GUESTS BEYOND
THE RAIL AND IN THE GALLERY
PLEASE RISE WILL BE LED IN
PRAYER THIS AFTERNOON BY
SENATOR EGGMAN. WHICH WE'RE
GOING TO ASK YOU TO REMAIN
STANDING AND WILL BE LED IN THE
PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE BY SENATOR
DOLLY. SENATOR EGGMAN. THIS IS
MY BROTHER THAT DELAY MAY NOT
SEE I BE AWARE OF THE SILENT
GOD WHO STANDS BY ME THAT
THOUGH I MAY NOT FEEL I BE
AWARE OF THE MIGHTY LOVE WHICH
DOGGEDLY FOLLOWS ME. THAT
THOUGH I MAY NOT RESPOND I BE
AWARE THAT GOD MY SILENCE
MIGHTY GOD WE EACH EACH DAY
QUIETLY HOPEFULLY PERSISTENTLY
WHICH FOR EACH DAY AND THROUGH
EACH NIGHT FOR ME FOR ME ALONE
A MAN FROM EDWINA GATELEY
THOUGH THERE WAS NO PATH SO I
TRIED. MEMBERS PLEASE JOIN ME
IN THE FLAG SALUTE I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE FLAG. AMERICA AND TO
THE REPUBLIC FOR WHICH IT
STANDS ONE NATION UNDER GOD
INDIVISIBLE WITH LIBERTY AND
JUSTICE FOR ALL. MEMBERS TODAY
WE'RE CELEBRATING A BIRTHDAY.
WELL SHE WE. YEAH WELL HE'S
GOING TO MISS IT WE'RE
CELEBRATING SENATOR STERN'S
BIRTHDAY SO LET'S WISH SENATORS
STERN A HAPPY BIRTHDAY. I GUESS
NOT. MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR
WILL BE DEEMED READ MESSAGES
FROM THE ASSEMBLY WILL BE
DEEMED READ REPORTS OF
COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED MOTIONS
AND RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES.
WITHOUT OBJECTION OF FALLING
RESOLUTIONS WILL BE PLACED ON
TODAY'S SPECIAL CONSENT
CALENDAR. ITEM SIXTY ONE ACR
TWENTY TWO ITEM SIXTY TWO ACR
THIRTY FOUR ITEM SIXTY THREE
ACR THIRTY EIGHT ITEM SIXTY
FOUR ACR TWENTY THREE AN ITEM
SIXTY FIVE ACR FORTY THREE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION THE FOLLOWING
BILLS WITH FOUR MINUTES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED FILE ITEM TWENTY NINE
S. B. FIFTY TWO. FILE ITEM
TWENTY SIX SB. SEVEN TWO ONE.
MEMBERS ARE NOW MOVING TO
CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY FILE
WE HAVE SECOND READING ITEMS
ONE THROUGH SEVENTEEN MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE RATE. SENATE
BILL THREE SIXTY SEVEN WITH
AMENDMENTS SIX EIGHTY TWO WITH
AMENDMENTS TO FORTY FIVE WITH
AMENDMENTS FIVE TEN WITH
AMENDMENTS FIVE TWENTY ONE WITH
AMENDMENTS SENATE BILL LEVIN
WITH AMENDMENTS SENATE BILL TWO
EIGHTY THREE. SECOND READING
WILL BE DEEMED READ. NOW
MEMBERS WERE MOVING TO
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENTS. ITEMS
NINETEEN TO TWENTY ONE SENATOR
LAYERED ARE YOU PREPARED. I AM
OF IS THE PRESIDENT LET'S BEGIN-
WE'RE DOING THESE INDIVIDUALLY
NINETEEN TWENTY AND TWENTY ONE
CORRECTLY THE END OF FILE ITEM
NINETEEN IS THE CONFIRMATION OF
ROBERT BARTON TO THE BOARD OF
PAROLE HEARINGS- HE SERVED AS A
COMMISSIONER SINCE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN HE'S WORKED AS AN
OFFICER IN THE FRESNO COUNTY
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT AS A
DEPUTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY AND AS
pDEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION. HE WAS APPROVED
BY THE RULES COMMITTEE ON MARCH
TWENTY FOURTH ONE OF FIVE A
VOTE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
IPHONE. ANIES DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE APPOINTMENT.
HEARING SEE ON MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN AYE
ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE BATES.
BAKER HI PORGES. BRADFORD HI
CABALLERO FIVE COURTESY HI
DALLY NO DODD. HI THE RAZA I
EGGMAN I GLAZER FIVE GONZALEZ
HIGH GROWTH. HERTZBERG I HUESO.
HI HER TADO HI JONES NO
KAMLAGER. HI LAYARD HI LEYVA.
HI LIMóN. MCGUIRE HI MELENDEZ
NO MAN HI NEWMAN AYE NIELSEN. A
TELEPHONE. PAN HI PORTANTINO HI
ROTH SORRY RUBIO HI SKINNER. I
STERN AYE NUMBER FIVE WHAT KIND
OF SKI HI WIENER AYE WILK NOW.
M. SURGERY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. BATES NO PORGES.
GROVE LIMóN. NIELSEN. NO THAT
SHOW BOTH. FIVE THIRTY NO SIX
THE POINT MINUTES CONFIRMED.
YOU KNOW NOW TO FILE ITEM
TWENTY THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
FILE ITEM TWENTY IS THE
CONFIRMATION OF CAVAN CHAPELLE
MINERVA DILATORY NEIL SCHNEIDER
AND WILLIAM SULLIVAN TO THE
BOARD OF PAROLE HEARINGS
THEY'RE ALL CONSIDERED TOGETHER
ALL FOUR COMMISSIONERS WERE
APPROVED BY THE SENATE RULES
COMMITTEE ON MARCH TWENTY
FOURTH ON A FIVE OH VOTE. I
WOULD ASK FOR AN IPHONE. THANK
YOU ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON BILL POINTS OINTMENTS.
C. NINE MEN SIGNATURE PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN HI HI
ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE BATES.
BAKER HI FORGES. BRADFORD HI
CABALLERO HI PROTESTING I DALLY.
DODD HI TO RAZA HI EGGMAN I
GLAZER. HI GONZALEZ FIVE GROWTH.
HERTZBERG HI WITH SO HI HER
TADO HI JONES. KAMLAGER HI
LAYARD. HI LEYVA. HI LIMóN.
MCGUIRE HI MELENDEZ NO MAN HI
NEWMAN. HI NIELSEN. I CHIRLA.
PAN AYE PORTANTINO. HI ROTH. HI
RUBIO FIVE SKINNER. HI STERN HI
AMBERG I WHITE HOUSE SKI HI
WIENER. HI WILK NO. M. SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
BATES. PORGES DALLY. GROWTH
JONES. LIMóN NIELSEN. CONTROL
OF BOTH. HIGHS THIRTY KNOWS TO
APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED NOW
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM TWENTY
ONE THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT FILE
ITEM- TWENTY ONE IS THE
CONFIRMATION OF LAND EAGER TO
THE TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION
SHE HAS BEEN PRESIDENT AND
CHIEF EXECUTIVE OFFICER AT THE
FRESNO. COUNTY ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT CORPORATION SINCE
TWO THOUSAND NINE SHE'S A BOARD
MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARD
CALIFORNIA PARTNERSHIP FOR SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY AND THE
CALIFORNIA INTERNATIONAL TRADE
AND INVESTMENT COUNSEL- I
ASTRONOMICAL. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
APPOINTMENT. HEARING SEEN. NINE
I WAS CENTER A TODDLE. THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT A GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS TODAY I RISE
IN SUPPORT OF APPOINTMENT OF
LEON EAGER TO THE
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION
LIANAS PRESIDENT ZERO FRESNO
COUNTY ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
CORPORATION WOULD HELP WHICH
HELPS BOLSTER THE REGION'S
ECONOMIC GROWTH THROUGH VARIOUS
PROGRAMS AND INITIATIVES THAT
ATTRACT INVESTMENT HARPER
KRUGMAN AND RETENTION AS WELL
AS HELPFUL BUSINESSES EXPAND.
LIANE IS A GENEROUS AND
COMMUNITY DRIVEN AND FOCUSED
PERSON WHO HAS HELPED BROKER
MANY PUBLIC PRIVATE
INITIATIVES. SOME INCLUDING IN
MY OWN SMALL TOWN OF SINGER. AS
WELL AS WORK TO IMPROVE THE
CONDITIONS OF THOSE WHO LIVE IN
HER. COMMUNITY IT IS THROUGH
HER ABILITY TO BUILD COALITIONS
AS WELL ADDS. HER COAT AT CHAIR
SHIP AT WORK PRESENT WORKS THAT
I AM SURE SHE HAS NOT ONLY
EXPERIENCED ADVOCATE FOR THE
CENTRAL VALLEY. BUT ALSO THE
COMPASSION SHOULD CONSIDER THE
OVERALL IMPACTS POLICIES WILL
HAVE THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
WHICH IS WHY I AM ASKING FOR AN
AYE VOTE TODAY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU ANY ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
OF THE VERY ON THE APPOINTED.
AND SHE NINE MINUTES SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN HI
ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE BATES
NO BAKER. HI FORGES. BRADFORD
HI CABALLERO HI CORTESE I DALY
NO DODD. FIVE TORONTO HI EGGMAN
HI GLAZER. HI GONZALEZ BY
GROWTH. HERTZBERG HI HUESO. HI
HURTADO HI JONES NO KAMLAGER HI
LAYERED HI LEYVA HI LIMóN.
MCGUIRE HI MELENDEZ NO MAN HI
NEWMAN HI NIELSEN. BUT CHAU
VOTE. NO PAN HI PORTANTINO HI
ROTH. HI RUBIO HI SKINNER. HI
STERN HI I'M BURKE ALL RIGHT HI
WHITE HOUSE SKI. HI WIENER. I
WILK NO. SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. PORGES GROVE.
LIMóN NIELSEN. VICE THIRTY
KNOWS SIX THE APPOINTMENT IS
CONFIRMED MEMBERS BEFORE MOVING
TO THE SENATE THIRD READING
AGAIN WE WANT TO TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO WISH A VERY
HAPPY BIRTHDAY TO SENATOR STERN
HAPPY BIRTHDAY CENTER STERN.
MOVING ON TO SENATE THIRD
READING. WE HAVE SIX ITEMS
FIRST UP IS FILE ITEM THIRTY.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE RE.
SENATE BILL SEVENTY THREE BY
SENATOR WIENER AN ACTUAL
LEADING TO PROBATION SOONER
WITHIN ARE YOU PREPARED. THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES I
RISE TODAY TO PRESENT SB
SEVENTY THREE WHICH WILL REPEAL
MANDATORY MINIMUM SENTENCES FOR
PEOPLE CONVICTED. OF CERTAIN
NONVIOLENT DRUG OFFENSES AND
INSTEAD PROVIDE JUDGES WITH THE
DISCRETION TO EITHER SEND
SOMEONE TO JAIL OR GROUND
PROBATION ON A CASE BY CASE
BASIS. THIS BILL IS A SMALL
STEP TOWARD ENDING MASS
INCARCERATION IN THE FAILED WAR
ON DRUGS WHICH HAS DEVASTATED
CALIFORNIA FAMILIES AND
SIGNIFICANTLY AFFECTS OUR STATE
BUDGET. UNDER CURRENT LAW
CALIFORNIA STILL CONTINUES TO
PROHIBIT JUDGES FROM USING
THEIR DISCRETION TO ORDER
PROBATION IN CASES INVOLVING
CERTAIN NONVIOLENT DRUG
OFFENSES. WERE TYING THE HANDS
OF THESE JUDGES AND REQUIRING
THAT IN EVERY SINGLE CASE. VAN
CARCERI THESE DEFENDANTS EVEN
WHEN THE JUDGE BELIEVES THAT
UNDER THE CIRCUMSTANCES A
PERSON WOULD BE BETTER
REHABILITATED WITH SUPERVISED
PROBATION IN THE COMMUNITY.
NOTHING AND SB SEVENTY THREE
LOWERS THE EXISTING UPPER
PENALTIES FOR THESE OFFENSES.
AND NOTHING INDUSTRY SEVENTY
THREE PREVENTS THE JUDGE FROM
SENDING SOMEONE TO JAIL IF THE
JUDGE BELIEVES THAT IT IS
APPROPRIATE UNDER THE
CIRCUMSTANCES OF THE CRIME.
THIS BILL IS A MODERN ASSIDUOUS
MEASURED AND MODEST AND
COMMONSENSE SOLUTION TO HELP
COURTS REDUCE MASS
INCARCERATION SENTENCING
WITHOUT JEOPARDIZING PUBLIC
SAFETY. SB SEVENTY THREE ALLOWS
JUDGES TO WEIGH THE FACTS OF
THE CASE AND TO MAKE AN
INFORMED DECISION. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU NEED THIS OR
DEBATE ON THE ITEMS SENATOR
NELSON. TURNO SEN OKAY NO ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. HEARING AND SEEING NINE.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN HI ARCHULETA ATKINS
AYE BATES. BOARD BAKER. HI
FORTUS. BRADFORD HI CAN I OTHER
HI CORTESE HI DALLY NO DODD. HI
TORONTO HI EGGMAN. HI GLAZER.
HI GONZALEZ HIGH GROWTH. NO
HERTZBERG. HI HUESO. HI HER
TADO NO JONES. NO KAMLAGER.
LAYARD HI LEYVA HI LIMóN.
MCGUIRE FIVE MELENDEZ NO MAN.
NO NEWMAN. NIELSEN NO A SHOW OF
THOSE. NO PAN FIVE PORTANTINO.
ROTH HI RUBIO FIVE SKINNER AYE
STERN. HI I'M BURKE. WHITE
HOUSE SKI FIVE WIENER HI WILK
NOW MMHM SURGERY PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ARCHULETA
BATES NO FORTUS. KAMLAGER HI
LIMóN. NEWMAN. PORTANTINO HI
AMBERG. HIS TWENTY FIVE MILLS
TEN THE MEASURE PASSES WE KNOW
NOW TO FILE ITEM FORTY SEVEN
SENATOR LAYERED ARE YOU
PREPARED FOR THAT ITEM WITH
THAT ITEM. I'M SECRETARY PLEASE
RATE. SENATE BILL FOR SEVENTY
NINE BY SENATOR LAYERED AND
ACTUALLY DIDN'T ELECTRICITY.
EARLIER THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
PRESIDENT- DURING MY TIME IN
THE ASSEMBLY IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHT I AUTHORED ASSEMBLY BILL
TWO FOUR SIX SIX CREATING TO
RENEWABLE ENERGY SELF
GENERATION BILL CREDIT TRANSFER
PROGRAM. AND IT ALLOWS CITIES
AND COUNTIES TO GENERATE
RENEWABLE ENERGY IN ONE
LOCATION FOR USE BY ONE OF
THEIR PROPERTIES IN ANOTHER
PART OF THE JURISDICTION FOR
EXAMPLE A CITY COULD HAVE SOLAR
PANELS ON THE ROOF OF THE
MUNICIPAL PARKING LOT. AND THEN
USE THAT SAME AMOUNT OF ENERGY
TO POWER THE MUNICIPAL SWIMMING
POOL IN ANOTHER LOCATION SINCE
TWO THOUSAND EIGHT THERE BEEN
THREE SUBSEQUENT BILLS IN IN
TWO THOUSAND NINE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BLUMENFELD EXPANDED THIS
TO UC AND C. ISSUES IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
OBERNOLTE EXPANDED THE PROGRAM
TO INCLUDE JOINT POWERS
AUTHORITIES. IN TWENTY EIGHT
ELEVEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER GORDON
EXPANDED THE AMOUNT OF THE
CAPACITY OF A POWER PLANT THIS
BILL EXPENSES PROGRAM TO
INCLUDE TRIBAL GOVERNMENTS WITH
ALL THE SAME PROVISIONS THAT
EXIST FOR PRE EXISTING
GOVERNMENT AND EDUCATIONAL
ENTITIES IT PASSED UNANIMOUSLY
IN UTILITIES AND ENERGY THERE'S
NO KNOWN OPPOSITION I
ASTRONOMICAL. THANK ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. HEARING SEEN NONE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON FILE ITEM FORTY SEVEN. ALLEN
HI ARCHULETA HI ATKINS FIVE
BATES HI BAKER. HI PORGES.
PORGES. BRADFORD HI CABALLERO I
CORTES HE HI DALLY HI DODD. HI
TORONTO HI EGGMAN I GLAZER HI
GONZALEZ HIGH GROWTH HI
HERTZBERG HI HUESO. I HER TADO
HI JONES. HI KAMLAGER HI
LAYERED HI LEYVA HI LIMóN
MCGUIRE. HI MELENDEZ FIVE
MILLION HI NEWMAN HI NIELSEN.
BY A SHOW OF BOTH. HI PAN AYE
PORTANTINO HI ROTH I RUBIO. HI
SKINNER. HI STERN HI I'M BURKE
HI WHITE HOUSE HE FIVE WIENER.
HI WILK. HI PORGES HI. HIGHS
THIRTY NINE NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES NOW WE'RE MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM FORTY EIGHT. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE RATE. SENATE
BILL SIX FOURTEEN BY SENATOR
ARCHULETA AN ACT RELATING TO
THE MILITARY AND MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION THEREFORE. THANK
YOU CENTER ARTILLERY THANK YOU
MR PRESIDENT I RISE TODAY TO
PRESENT SENATE BILL. SIX ONE
FOUR SIX FOURTEEN CALIFORNIA
HAS ALWAYS LED THE WAY IN
PROVIDING PROGRAM SUPPORTING
AND HELPING SERVICE MEMBERS AND
THEIR FAMILIES WHENEVER
POSSIBLE AND HOWEVER POSSIBLE.
IN TWENTY TWELVE THE LEGISLATOR.
AUTHORIZED THE CREATION OF A
SPECIAL FUNDS TO BETTER
ADMINISTER MORALE WELFARE AND
RECREATION PROGRAMS GRADING THE
MILITARY DEPARTMENT SUPPORT
FUNDS IN THE TREASURY. HOWEVER
STATE CONTRACTING LAW CURRENTLY
PROHIBITS THE MILITARY
DEPARTMENT FROM USING DONATED
FUNDS TO ADMINISTER THE MORALE
WELFARE AND RECREATION PROGRAMS.
SENATE BILL SIX FOURTEEN SIX TO
FIX THIS OVERSIGHT BY
AUTHORIZING THE MILITARY
DEPARTMENT TO ENTER INTO A
MEMORANDUM OF AGREEMENT WITH
NONPROFIT MILITARY OR VETERANS
ORGANIZATIONS. THESE
MEMORANDUMS OF AGREEMENT WILL
ALLOW THE DEPARTMENT TO CONDUCT
CALIFORNIA MILITARY DEPARTMENT
SUPPORT FUND ACTIVITIES FOR THE
BENEFIT OF THE MILITARY
FAMILIES AND SOLDIERS AND
AIRMAN IN THE CALIFORNIA
NATIONAL GUARD. SENATE BILL SIX
FOURTEEN WOULD ALSO AUTHORIZE
THE MILITARY DEPARTMENTS TO
SPEND MONEY IN THE CALIFORNIA
MILITARY DEPARTMENT SUPPORT
FUND TO PAY ENTITIES THAT HAVE
ENTERED INTO MEMORANDUMS OF
AGREEMENT. THESE MONIES CAN
ONLY BE USED TO SUPPORT THESE
MORALE WELFARE AND RECREATION
ACTIVITIES IF THEY ARE DONATED
FOR THAT PURPOSE. CALIFORNIA
OWES A DEBT OF GRATITUDE TO OUR
SERVICE MEN AND WOMEN AS WELL
AS THEIR FAMILIES AND SENATE
BILL SIX FOURTEEN WHAT AID THEM
IN ADDRESSING THE NEED THAT IS
OFTEN COMES WITH DEPLOYMENT.
MORALE WELFARE AND RECREATION
PROGRAMS ARE JUST ONE OF THE
STEPS WE CAN TAKE TO ENSURE
THAT THIS DEBT. DOES NOT GO
UNPAID. S. SENATE BILL SIX
FOURTEEN ENSURES THAT WE WILL
BE ABLE TO PROVIDE THESE
PROGRAMS TO FAMILIES WITHOUT
DELAY DURING THEIR TIMES OF
NEED THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED NO
NO VOTE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM. MEMBERS WITHOUT
OBJECTION THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION TO USING A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON THE SIDE
OF. YOU SEE NINE. ALL EYES
THIRTY NINE DOES IT ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES. EXPEL MEMBERS
WERE MOVING ON NOW TO FILE ITEM
FORTY NINE SENATOR MCGUIRE
YOU'RE PREPARED MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE RATE SENATE BILL SIX
EIGHTY FIVE BY SENATOR MCGUIRE
AN ACT RELATING TO EMPLOYMENT-
MAGOR. RIGHT GOOD AFTERNOON
GOOD AFTERNOON MR RESIDENT AND
MEMBERS- HONORED TO BE IN A
PRISON SB SIX EIGHTY FIVE
NEARLY A QUARTER OF ALL
CALIFORNIA PAIR SHIPPED IN THE
FRESH MARKET COME FROM THE
BUTTE COUNTY OF LAKE IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA IN MISTER
PRESIDENT IT'S BEEN GENERATIONS
AT LAKE COUNTY RESIDENTS OF
WORK THE PAIR HARVEST TO ENSURE
THOSE SWEET JUICY CALIFORNIA
DELICACIES CAN BE DELIVERED TO
STORE SHELVES AROUND THE NATION
IN THE WORLD BUT THE CHALLENGES
THE PAIR'S HARVEST HERE IN
CALIFORNIA IT'S EXTREMELY SHORT
AT LAST ONLY FOUR TO SEVEN
WEEKS AROUND. AUGUST OF EACH
YEAR AND WIN THE PEAR HARVEST
IS AT ITS PEAK IT COMPETES WITH
THE NUMBER NE ECONOMIC DRIVER
IN THE COUNTY IN ITS TOURISM
DUE TO LABOR SHORTAGES SB SIXTY
FIVE EXTENDS THE STATE LAW THAT
ALLOWS SIXTEEN SEVEN ZERO TO
WORK OVERTIME WHEN PACKING
PEARS IN AUGUST WHEN SCHOOL IS
NOT IN SESSION TO ALLEVIATE THE
SUMMER LABOR SHORTAGE OF WORK
PERMITS ARE ADMINISTERED AND
OVERSEEN TO THE LATE COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION AND ARE
DIRECTLY SUPERVISED BY THE
COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT WHO
SUPPORTS THIS PROGRAM. THE
PROGRAM IS ALSO OVERSEEN ON THE
STATEWIDE LEVEL BY THE OFFICE
OF THE LABOR COMMISSIONER NOW
IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE WORK
PERMITS CANNOT BE ISSUE DURING
THE SCHOOL YEAR WHICH MEANS
STUDENTS CANNOT WORK WHEN
SCHOOL IS IN SESSION- AND IN
THIS LEGISLATURE ALONG WITH
PREVIOUS GOVERNORS HAVE SIGNED
THIS BILL INTO LAW SINCE
NINETEEN NINETY SIX WITH
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. BUT
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. HEARING
SEEN NO MICROPHONES UP. MADAM
SECRETARY WILL THIS ITEM IS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
USING THE UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL
ON FILE ITEM FORTY NINE.
HEARING CITY NINE. HIGHS THIRTY
NINE KNOWS ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES NOW MEMBERS WERE MOVING
ON TO FILE ITEM FIFTY. SENATOR
JONES ARE YOU PREPARED FOR FILE
ITEM FIFTY MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE RATE. SENATE BILL TWO
EIGHTY EIGHT BY SENATOR JONES
AND ACTUALLY IT INTO
CORPORATIONS. ENTER JONES THE
FLOOR'S YOURS THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT I'M PRESENTING- S. B.
TWO EIGHTY EIGHT TODAY SENATE
BILL TWO EIGHT ESTABLISHES A
SINGLE STEP CONVERSION PROCESS
FOR CALIFORNIA CORPORATIONS TO
BECOME FOREIGN CORPORATIONS
THIS BILL MAKE IT SLIGHTLY MORE
ATTRACTIVE FOR CORPORATIONS TO
INCORPORATE CALIFORNIA RATHER
THAN OUT OF STATE AND I ACTION
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM FILE
ITEM FIFTY. SEEING NO
MICROPHONES. MEMBERS THIS IS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
USING UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON
FILE ITEM FIFTY. SEEING NO
HANDS HIGHS THIRTY NINE KNOWS
IT ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES.
HELMUT MEMBERS MOVING ON TO NOW
LET ARE FINE I'M HERE ARE FILE
ITEM FIFTY SIX. SENATOR HUESO
ARE YOU PREPARED FOR FILE ITEM
FIFTY SIX. SECRETARY PLEASE
RATE SENATE JOINT RESOLUTION TO
BY SENATOR HUESO RELATIVE TO
IMMGRATION REFORM. GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR I RISE
TO PRESENT S. J. R. TO A
RESOLUTION THAT WOULD CALL ON
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO ENACT
COMPREHENSIVE IMMIGRATION
REFORM CURRENTLY THERE ARE AN
ESTIMATED ELEVEN MILLION
UNDOCUMENTED AND IMMIGRANTS IN
THE UNITED STATES TWO POINT
FIVE MILLION WHICH CALL
CALIFORNIA HOME. ONE IN TEN
CALIFORNIA WORKERS IS
UNDOCUMENTED. A LOGICAL AND
STREAMLINED PATHWAY TO
CITIZENSHIP WOULD STIMULATE THE
ECONOMY BY ALLOWING
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS TO GET
COLLEGE FREE. COLLEGE I'M SORRY
TO GET COLLEGE DEGREES BY HOME
START NEW COMPANIES. THANK
CREATE LEGAL TAX PAYING JOBS
FINALLY AFFORDING THEM A CHANCE
AT THE AMERICAN DREAM. SINCE
THE- HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
IMMIGRANTS INCLUDING DACA
RECIPIENTS WHO ALREADY
CONTRIBUTE TO THIS NATION BY
PAYING TAXES AND PROVING THAT
THEY DESERVE TO BE FULLY FULLY
INCORPORATE INTO OUR LEGAL
SYSTEM UNFORTUNATELY DO NOT
HAVE A PATHWAY TO
NATURALIZATION. THIS RESOLUTION
CALLS ON REFORMS BASED ON SIX
TENNIS THAT ARE OR AS FOLLOWS
NUMBER ONE MAINTAINING FAMILY
STRUCTURES TO CREATING A
PATHWAY TO CITIZENSHIP FOR DACA
RECIPIENTS THREE EXPANDED
ELIGIBILITY FOR ASYLUM ASYLUM
SEEKERS FOR. UPGRADING THE
CURRENT VISA PROGRAMS IN ORDER
TO HAVE THE LEGAL WORK FORCE IN
THE SYSTEM THAT BETTER FORCES
LABOR PROTECTIONS FIVE
ELIMINATING THE TERM ALIEN FROM
ALL IMMIGRATION LAWS AND SIX.
BUT PULLED INTO PROCESS AS WELL
AS THE INHERENT RIGHTS OF ALL
IMMIGRANTS. IT'S WOULD CALL FOR
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT T
IMPLEMENT COMPREHENSIVE
IMMIGRATION REFORMS ARE GUIDED
BY EMPATHY INCLUSION AND
OPPORTUNITY THREE FIVE THREE
VALUES THAT HAVE HELPED
CALIFORNIA BECOME ONE OF THE
MOST PROGRESSIVE. AND
ECONOMICALLY SUCCESSFUL STATES
IN THE WORLD I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT FOR AN AYE
VOTE FOR THIS TIMELY AND
IMPORTANT RESOLUTION THANK YOU
MR PRESIDENT. THANK YOU ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM SENATOR PAN. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT- SENATORS I TO RISE
IN SUPPORT OF THIS YEAR TO I
WANT TO THANK MY GOOD FRIEND
FROM SAN DIEGO FOR BRINGING
THIS UP BILL FORD AS CHAIR OF
THE ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS I WOULD MAKE
NOTE THAT ACTUALLY OVER HALF OF
ALL ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDERS IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
IMMIGRANTS- AND THEY HAVE
CONTRIBUTED MIGHTILY. TO OUR
STATE. WE NEED TO BE SURE THERE
IS A PATH FIRST- NATURALIZATION
AND CITIZENSHIP- WE NEED REFORM
IT'S BEEN. WAIT TIME IT'S BEEN
DECADES SINCE CONGRESS AND THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAVE FINALLY
ADDRESS THIS. CRITICAL ISSUE-
FOR NOT ONLY CALIFORNIA THE FOR
THIS ENTIRE COUNTRY I ARJUN AYE
VOTE ON THIS YEAR TO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. M. C. NINE SIR HUESO
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT AND I VOTE FOR THIS
TIMELY AND IMPORTANT MEASURE
THANK YOU THANK YOU. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN HI ARCHULETA HI ATKINS
FIVE BASED. BACKER HI PORGES.
BRADFORD LARA HI CUT BY ADAM
HIGH COURT CORTESE HI DOLLY.
DODD HI TERRAZZO HI EGGMAN FIVE
GLAZER I GONZALEZ BY GROWTH.
HERTZBERG HI HUESO HI HER TADO
HI JONES. KAMLAGER I GLARED HI
LEYVA HI LIMóN. MCGUIRE HI
MELENDEZ. MAN HI NEWMAN HI
NIELSEN. A SHOW OF BOTH. PAN
FIVE PORTANTINO HI ROTH HI
RUBIO HI SKINNER. HI STERN HI
AMBERG HI WHITE HOUSE SKI FIVE
WIENER AYE WILK. BUT SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
DALLY NO. GROVE JONES. LIMóN
MELENDEZ. NO NIELSEN. PHOTO OF
BOTH. HI WILK HI. FIVE THIRTY
TWO KNOWS TO THE MEASURE PASSES
WELL MEMBERS WERE MOVING TO
SPECIAL CONSENT CALENDAR WE
HAVE FIVE ITEMS THERE.
SECRETARY PLEASE READ THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. OKAY.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION.
TWENTY TO THIRTY FOUR THIRTY
EIGHT TWENTY THREE AND ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION FORTY
THREE. MEMBERS ARE THERE ANY
ITEMS. THAT YOU WANT TO REMOVED
FROM THE CONSENT GALLAGHER.
HEARING AND SEEING NONE M.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON ACR TWENTY TWO ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. ALLEN. HI
ARCHULETA HI ATKINS AYE BATES.
HI BAKER. HI PORGES. HI
BRADFORD HI CUT BY ADAM HIGH
COURT TESTING HI DALLY. HI DODD
HI TO RAZA HI EGGMAN HI GLAZER
HI GONZALEZ HIGH GROWTH. HI
HERTZBERG HI HUESO HI FURTADO
FIVE JONES HI KAMLAGER HI THERE.
HI LEYVA. HI LIMóN. MCGUIRE
FIVE MELENDEZ FIVE MILLION HI
NEWMAN HI NIELSEN. BY A CHIRLA
VOTE. HI PAN HI PORTANTINO. HI
ROTH HI RUBIO HI SKINNER. HI
STERN HI I'M BURKE ALL RIGHT HI
MY CLOSELY HI WIENER AYE WILK
HI. HIGHS THIRTY NINE NO ZERO
ON ACR TWENTY TWO- ICE THIRTY
NINE NO ZERO ON THE BALANCE OF
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. MEMBERS
NOW WE'RE MOVING TO COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCEMENTS. ARE THERE ANY
COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENTS YES.
COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENT SENATOR
HUESO IS THERE A COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCEMENT. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT UPON THE GERMAN OF
THE SENATE WE WILL BE MEETING
WITH THE ENERGY UTILITIES AND
TELECOMMUNICATIONS HERE ON THE
SENATE FLOOR. THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON UTILITIES WILL BE
MEETING ON ENERGY AND UTILITIES
WILL BE MEETING IN THE CHAMBER.
AFTER ADJOURNMENT ALLOWING
ENOUGH TIME TO CLEAN THE
CHAMBERS. NOW WE'RE MOVING TO A
SUPPLEMENTAL FILE MINUTES
SECRETARY PLEASE RATE. OKAY.
MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY
PLACE RICK. OKAY. MESSAGES FROM
THIS ASSEMBLY MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE RATE. MADAM PRESIDENT I
AM. REALLY THINK ABOUT. MADAM
PRESIDENT I AM DIRECTED TO
INFORM YOUR HONORABLE BODY THAT
THE ASSEMBLY AMENDED AND ON
THIS DAY PASSED AS AMENDED SB
EIGHTY FIVE AND RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR HONORABLE BODY TO
CONCURRENCE AT AMENDMENTS TO
SUE PARKER CHIEF CLERK OF THE
ASSEMBLY ABOVE BILL READ ORDER
TO UNFINISHED FILE. FILE. IS
NOW WE'RE MOVING TO THE
SUPPLEMENTAL FILE. FILE ITEM
SIXTY NINES CENTERS SKINNER YOU
PREPARE. M. SECRETARY PLEASE
RATE. SENATE BILL EIGHTY FIVE
BY THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
BUDGET AND FISCAL REVIEW AN ACT
RELATING TO THE STATE BUDGET
AND MAKING AN APPROPRIATION
THEREFORE TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY BUDGET BILL.
SKINNER SKINNER. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR PRESIDENT MEMBERS AND
VERY PLEASED TO BE ABLE TO
PRESENT TO YOU- SB EIGHTY FIVE
WHICH IS A BUDGET BILL JUNIOR
ASSOCIATED WITH THE BUDGET ACT
OF TWENTY TWENTY. THE REASON
THAT I AM VERY PLEASED TO BE
ABLE TO PRESENT IT TO YOU IS. I
THINK WE ALL. ARE VERY KEENLY
AWARE OF HOW DRY THIS YEAR. IS
ALREADY BEGUN. WHAT OUR SNOW
PACK IS LIKE. THE FACT THAT WE
ARE ALREADY HAVING HIGHER
TEMPERATURES AND WE'VE ALREADY
HAD A WILDFIRE IN SACRAMENTO.
AND OF COURSE THE LAST FEW
YEARS HAVE BEEN. EACH YEAR
EXCESSIVELY WORST WILDFIRE
SEASONS TO THE POINT THAT W
HAVE CLOSE TO EIGHT OR NINE
MONTHS A YEAR NOW THAT OUR
WILDFIRE SEASON. AND SO WHAT
THIS BILL OES IS IT IS OUR
EARLY ACTION WILD FIRE PACKAGE
TO HELP US MAKE SOME
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS IN
WILDFIRE PREVENTION AND
RESILIENCY. SO THE BILL IS A
TOTAL OF FIVE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY SIX MILLION FOUR HUNDRED
ELEVEN MILLION OF IT IS GENERAL
FUND AND A HUNDRED AND TWENTY
FIVE MILLION IS GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION FUND. AND IT INCLUDES
TWO HUNDRED AND THIRTY FIRST
GIVES ME TWO HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
THREE MILLION FOUR WILDLANDS. A
HUNDRED NINETY EIGHT MILLION
FOR WILDFIRE FUEL BREAKS TWENTY
SEVEN MILLION FOR COMMUNITY
HARDENING TWENTY FIVE MILLION
FOR FORESTRY SECTOR ECONOMIC
STIMULUS. AND THREE MILLION FOR
SCIENCE BASED MANAGEMENT NOW
MUCH OF THESE INDIVIDUAL
CATEGORIES ARE GOING TO BE
GRANTS TO ENTITIES LIKE LAND
CONSERVANCIES AND THE VARIOUS
PROTECTION FIRE COUNCILS IN
ENTITIES THAT. ARE ENGAGED IN
THE VEGETATION REDUCTION AND
THE OTHER. THINGS THAT ARE
NEEDED TO HELP US. CREATE
BETTER RESILIENCY AND MORE-
WITH WILDFIRE MANAGEMENT NOT
FOR A WILDFIRE TO OCCUR BUT
RATHER TO HELP US PREVENT THEM
OR AT LEAST PREVENT THEIR QUICK
SPREAD- ADDITIONALLY IT
INCLUDES THE BILL THAT IS THIS
IS OUTSIDE OF THE WILDFIRE PART
IT INCLUDES THREE POINT. THREE
FIVE MILLION TO FIND A
TECHNICAL. IN MY PROGRAM FOR
SMALL MID SIZE AND UNDERS FOR
AND CAL. AND IT AUTHORIZES ONE.
FIVE HUNDRED AND TWENTY DOLLARS
START. TO IN THE MURDER CARE
BRIDGE PROGRAM THAT PROVIDE
CARE FOR FOSTER YOUTH. IT
ADDITIONALLY APPROPRIATE. EIGHT
HUNDRED THOUSAND TO SUPPORT OUR
STATE WIDE LUNCH AT THE LIBRARY
PROGRAM FOR THIS SUMMER TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. AND THEN MAKES
VARIOUS CLARIFYING AND
TECHNICAL CHANGES AND WITH THAT
I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU HE FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE SENATOR DELHI. THANK
YOU. MR PRESIDENT- AND
SUGGEST WE SAW THIS BILL JUST A
COUPLE HOURS AGO AND IN THE
BUDGET I JUST WANT TO SHARE YOU
KNOW MANY OF YOU HAVE BEEN. ON
TOURS. OUT TO THE FOREST WITH
MYSELF AND- AND YOU'VE SEEN
THAT THE DEVASTATION YOU'VE
SEEN WAYS TO PREVENT- WILDFIRES
FROM TRAVELING FAST IN WHAT WE
CALL CROWN FIRES IN THE FOREST
AND THE ABILITY TO BE ABLE TO
THIN THE FOREST AND ALLOW THE
FIRE TO COME DOWN. UNDER THE
GROUND WORKERS WERE NATURALLY
WOULD HAVE BEEN PRIOR TO ALMOST
A HUNDRED YEARS OF FIRE
SUPPRESSION SO WE HAVE- CREATED
THE PROBLEM ALONG WITH THE
RISING TEMPERATURES IN THE
SHORTNESS OF OUR SEASONS AND
THE DIFFERENCE IN SNOW PACK.
WE'VE SEEN THIS- THESE
CATASTROPHIC EVENTS LIKE WE HAD
LAST YEAR WE SAW. YOU KNOW FOUR
POINT TWO MILLION ACRES IN
CALIFORNIA BURN SO I WANT TO
JUST APPLAUD THE BUDGET
COMMITTEES AT THE LEGISLATURE
AND ADMINISTRATION FOR MAKING
THIS FIRST EARLY ACTION ITEM.
SO THAT WE CAN ACTUALLY. GET
THESE FUNDS THROUGH GRANTS TO-
CONSERVANCY'S LIKE THIS YEAR
ABOUT A CONSERVANCY TO OUR OUR
CD'S TO OUR FIRE SAFE COUNCILS-
IT ALL OUT TO THE STATE IS NOT
JUST A FOREST WHERE WE THINK OF
TREES BURNING BUT IT'S ALSO.
ALONG THE COASTLINES WHERE WE
HAVE EDUCATION WE SAW- IN
MALIBU WHERE WE SAW THE MUD
SLIDES AFTER FIRE SO IT'S
GETTING IN AND DOING THE RIGHT
WORK EARLY ON- AND AS AS YOU.
IT WAS NOTED EARLIER BY THE
BUDGET CHAIR- YOU KNOW WE'RE
WE'RE TO DROUGHT THERE'S THERE
WERE SIGNIFICANTLY BEHIND THIS
YEAR AND THE QUICKER WE GET
THIS MONEY THE GROUND. THE
BETTER OFF OUR COMMUNITIES ARE
GOING TO HAVE. IN DEFENSE OF-
THE UPCOMING FIRE SEASON SO I
WANT TO SUPPORT THIS BILL
RIGHT. SB EIGHTY FIVE. A
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR NELSON. SENATE
PRESIDENT LADIES ON THE SENATE
FINALLY THE TIDE HAS TURNED.
FOR MANY DECADES IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. THE POLICY WAS
INFORMED AS FAR AS FORCING
WILDLANDS LEAVE IT ALONE. THE
NEW LARGELY DID. AND THE RESULT.
IT'S BEEN A GROWTH OF FUEL
FILLER ENORMOUS. BUT NOW WITH
THE GUN TO HAVE THESE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS CATACLYSMIC FIRES.
AS SUCH MAGNITUDE. LITTLE TOWN
OF PARADISE COMPLETELY
DESTROYED AND EIGHTY FIVE
PEOPLE DIED. IN A FIRE IN NO
SMALL MEASURE BECAUSE OF
POLICIES OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. THE DID NOT ALLOW.
THE MANAGER OF THOSE FORESTS
AND WILDLANDS. SOME OF THAT
NEEDS REMOVING TREES REMOVING
BRUSH. AND ENHANCING THE
HABITAT ONE THING THAT NOBODY
EVER TALKS ABOUT RELATED TO
THESE CATACLYSMIC FIRES. IS ITS
IMPACT ON WILDLIFE. PROTECTING
THOSE WHO OF STOOD SO STRONGLY
AGAINST DOING ANYTHING THAT ARE
FORCED IN WILDLANDS. THEY SEEM
TO DISREGARD ALL OF THE
CRITTERS THE ANIMALS. THERE IN
THE FOURTH. BANISHED FIGURE
LITTLE BLOOD HERE BECAUSE THIS
DEEP IN MY HEART TWO YEARS AGO
I TOOK SOME OF US TO TOUR THE
PARADISE. TALKED ABOUT HOW THE
FIRE DEVASTATED THAT COMMUNITY.
AND ONE OF THE BACK ROADS WE
CAME UPON A LARGE BORE. THERE
ARE MANY UP THERE IN THOSE
HEELS. HE BEEN BARBECUED. BUT
NOT ON THE SPENT ON THAT
TERRIBLE FIRE. NOW THAT'S KIND
OF A HORROR STRICKEN THAT LOOK
AT SUCH DEVASTATION OF AN
ANIMAL. BUT IT'S APPROPRIATE
BECAUSE THAT IS WHAT HAPPENS.
TO OUR WILDLIFE AND THEN OUR
FISH AS A DEVASTATED SOILS. A
ROAD INTO OUR RIVERS AND OUR
STREAMS. THIS IS A VERY
POSITIVE STEP FORWARD. A VERY
SIGNIFICANT STEP FOR MORE SAFE
AND SANE FUTURE. AND IT'S GOING
TO HELP URBAN AREAS TO URBAN
LEGISLATORS MUCH DIDN'T PAY
ATTENTION TO THIS OVER THE
DECADES EITHER BECAUSE THEY
WERE NOT AFFECTED. BUT NOW THEY
ARE THESE FIRES HAVE BEEN
CROUCHED ON OUR URBAN
COMMUNITIES MARCHING RIGHT INTO
THEM. ONE THAT I USED TO
REPRESENT AND- SANTA ROSA.
NEVER HAD FIRES LIKE THIS RIDE
INTO TOWN. GOT A FIRE IN RED
BLUFF RIGHT TO VERY NEAR WHERE
WE LIVE. INTOWN IT IS TIME. AND
I SALUTE THE TIME. AND I SALUTE
TO CHANGE AND WE WILL BE BETTER
IF WE ARE SAFER FROM THESE
CATACLYSMIC FIRES WITH THE
MANAGEMENT OF THESE FOR SOME
WHILE LANCE AND THEY WILL OUR
LANDS AND OUR ANIMALS AND OUR
HUMANS. AND OUR HABITAT IN OUR
RESOURCES. WILL BE MORE
PRODUCTIVE. AND MORE HEALTHY
AND MORE SAFE. THANK YOU CENTER
ALERT. MISTER PRESIDENT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- HE DOES SENATOR-
FROM READING IS SAID TO HIM
THAT IS CORRECT. OF BECAUSE FOR
A HUNDRED YEARS FIRE
SUPPRESSION HAS BEEN THE ORDER
OF THE DAY IN OUR STATE OF
PEOPLE URBAN AND RURAL OF ALL
PARTIES EVERYONE THAT WAS THE
OPERATING THEORY. AND IT HAS
BUTTED UP AGAINST CLIMATE
CHANGE BECAUSE THE OTHER PART
OF THE PARADISE STORY IS THE
FACT THAT THAT FAR REMOVED AT
SIXTY ACRES A MINUTE SIXTY
ACRES A MINUTE. PEOPLE COULD
NOT OUTRUN THAT FIRE AND I WAS
THERE THREE DAYS AND SIX DAYS
IN NINE DAYS AFTER THAT FIRE I
SAW. THE DEMONSTRATION AND THE
SIGNIFICANT THING ABOUT WHAT'S
IN FRONT OF US IS THIS DOES
EVERYTHING TAKES THE FIRST
STEPS OF EVERYTHING WE NEED TO
DO. OUR WHETHER IT'S HEARTENING
OF BUILDINGS. WHETHER IT'S A
PRESCRIBED FIRE WEATHER RICH
FUELS MANAGEMENT WHETHER IT'S
RECOVERING- AND MORE
IMPORTANTLY WHETHER IT'S
WHETHER WE HAVE ENOUGH
RESOURCES TO FIGHT THE FIRE.
BECAUSE LAST AUGUST WELL ALL OF
YOU WERE HERE STRUGGLING WITH
THE END OF SESSION. I WAS AT
HOME WITH A FIRE THAT BROKE OUT
IN MY AREA THAT BURNED WITHIN
TWO MILES OF MY HOUSE. IN A
COASTAL USUALLY FOGGY SEASIDE
CITY WHERE THE RESOURCES WERE
SO STRESSED IN THE STRAIGHT IN
THE STATE THAT THAT FIRE WAS
BURNING THROUGH RURAL
RESIDENTIAL AREAS ON FOUGHT FOR
THREE OR FOUR DAYS. IT GOT TO
WITHIN TWO MILES OF THE CITY
LIMITS AND WE JUST HAD THE CITY
FIRE DEPARTMENT AT THE CITY
LIMITS ONE BIG WIND AND IT WAS
IN. A IN SO THE BIG QUESTION TO
IS ONE THAT IS ADDRESSED BY
THIS BOND IS HOW DO WE MAKE
SURE WE HAVE THE RESOURCES SO
WE ARE NOT STRETCHED THAT WAY
AGAIN. AND ALL THESE THINGS ARE
GOING TO BE THINGS THAT THIS IS
THE FIRST STEP OFF. THIS IS THE
NEWER NEWER NORMAL AND WE ARE
GOING TO HAVE TO DO FUELS
MANAGEMENT AND FORCE TREATMENT
AND BUILDING HARDENING AND HAVE
ENOUGH RESOURCES. TO DEAL WITH
THE FIRE INSURANCE PROBLEM
BECAUSE THEY WERE SEVENTY SEVEN
THOUSAND PEOPLE IN THE COUNTY
OF TWO HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
THIRTY THREE THOUSAND PEOPLE
WERE EVACUATED. AND WHEN THAT
HAPPENED MANY OF RETURN HOME TO
FOUND FIND CANCELLATION NOTICES
FOR THEIR FIRE INSURANCE IN THE
MAIL AFTER BEING OUT OF THEIR
HOUSE FOR TWELVE DAYS. SO THIS
IS IMPORTANT AND WE HAVE TO BE
READY TO DO THIS REGULARLY AND
IN DIFFERENT WAYS SO I STRONGLY
URGE AND I'VE FOUGHT AND THANK
EVERYBODY THAT. WORKED ON THIS
TOGETHER HERE TODAY. THANK YOU
SENATOR RUBIO. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
OF THE SENATE TODAY I'M PRICE
IN SUPPORT OF THE WILDFIRE
PREVENTION RESILIENCY EARLY
ACTION BUDGET PLAN. THIS
UNPRECEDENTED EARLY DEPLOYMENT
OF RESOURCES WILL PROTECT OUR
MOST VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES AND
AS WE HEARD IT'S NO LONGER JUST
THE FOREST THIS WILL HELP
MINIMIZE THE LOSS OF LIFE AND
PROPERTY. WHILE INVESTING IN
FOREST HEALTH WATERSHED
PROTECTION AND OTHER VITAL
ENVIRONMENTAL RESTORATION
PROJECTS. THIS EARLY INVESTMENT
THROUGHOUT THE STATE WILL HELP
PREPARE US. FOR ANOTHER
DEVASTATING WILDFIRE SEASON WE
KNOW THAT THE SEASONS ARE
GETTING LONGER. AND MORE
DEVASTATING AND WE'VE ALL
EXPERIENCED THEM CLOSER AND
CLOSER TO HOME. I WANT TO THANK
THE PRO TEM FOR HER LEADERSHIP
THE GREAT SENATOR FROM HILLS
BURKE FOR COACH SHARING THE
WATER WORKING GROUP WITH ME.
ALL THE GREAT SENATOR FROM
BERKELEY AND FREMONT FOR THEIR
COLLABORATION AND EVERYONE ELSE
FOR THEIR INPUT. THIS IS SUCH
AN IMPORTANT PACKAGE. THAT WILL
PUT SEVENTY THREE MILLION AND
KALIFORNIA FIRE PREVENTION
GRANT PROGRAM. WILL LSO
PROVIDE ASSISTANCE TO
LANDOWNERS CLEARING BRUSH FOR
CONDUCTING OTHER VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT PROJECTS IN ADDITION
ANOTHER SIXTY MILLION. WILL
GOING GRANTS TO THE OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES AND AGAIN
ALL THIS EARLY INVESTMENT IS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT. AS CHAIR
OF THE INSURANCE COMMITTEE I
ALSO KNOW THAT THIS PLAN WILL
HELP STRUGGLING HOMEOWNERS GET
ADEQUATE INSURANCE THEY'RE
STRUGGLING. BECAUSE IT'S
GETTING MORE EXPENSIVE EVERY
SINGLE DAY ESPECIALLY IN THE
HIGH FIRE RISK AREAS WOULD
CONTINUE TO BEST INVESTMENTS WE
CAN CREATE RESILIENT HOMES AND
COMMUNITIES. FINALLY THE BUDGET
ACTION WILL PROVIDE MUCH NEEDED
RESOURCES TO CONSERVANCIES
ACROSS THE STATE. AND WITH THAT
THANK YOU AND I URGE AND I VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR. COLLEGES
THERE'S A LOT TO ADD ON TO WHAT.
HAS ALREADY BEEN STATED BUT I
TO RISE IN SUPPORT OF SB EIGHTY
FIVE. IT IS MY HONOR TO
REPRESENT SENATE DISTRICT EIGHT
IN SOME OF YOU MAY OR MAY NOT
KNOW. THAT I HAVE ONE OF THOSE
VERY VERY LARGE GEOGRAPHICALLY
SENATE DISTRICTS INCLUDING ALL
OR PARTS OF ELEVEN COUNTIES.
ELEVEN FROM THE BASIN IN THE
FOOTHILLS OF THE MOUNTAINS. THE
CREEK FIRE THAT HAPPENED LAST
YEAR. HAPPEN IN MY TERRITORY IN
THE FRESNO AND MADERA COUNTIES.
THREE HUNDRED AND EIGHTY FIVE
THOUSAND ACRES. WERE DESTROYED.
NOT TO MENTION LIVES PROPERTY
PROSPECTS. I THINK THIS FIRE
HAS SHOWCASED THE
VULNERABILITIES THAT OUR SYSTEM
HAS WHETHER IT BE IN. PROPER
RESOURCE MANAGEMENT PUBLIC
SAFETYOUR INVESTMENT THE
OVERALL INFRASTRUCTURE OF HOW
THE CITY CALIFORNIA CAN DEAL
WITH SUCH COMPLEX IN DEMANDING
ENVIRONMENTAL CHALLENGES NO I
KNOW THAT ONE OF MY COLLEAGUES
EARLIER TALK ABOUT HOW MAYBE
THE TIDE HAS TURNED. THAT WE
HAVE SPENT SO MANY YEARS.
INVESTING IN- IN IN MAKING OF
POLITICAL INSIGHTS INTO CLIMATE
CHANGE. THAT WE HAVE NOT
NECESSARILY APPRECIATED ALL THE
TOOLS THAT WE HAVE AT OUR
DISPOSAL RIGHT NOW TO
CONTEMPLATE. PROPER FOREST
MANAGEMENT SKILLS- BREAKS ARE
HARDENING AND THAT'S WHAT
THAT'S WHAT SB EIGHTY FIVE DOES
IT'S A POSITIVE STEP IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION. IS IT PERFECT
NOW I DON'T THINK IT IS BUT I
GOTTA TELL YOU IT IS A DEFINITE
STEP IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION
THAT WE HAVE THESE THIS TYPE OF
CAPITAL ON AN EXPEDITED BASIS.
BEING INVESTED INTO HARDENING.
TO FIRE BREAKS- INVESTMENT IN
PUBLIC SAFETY RESOURCES ALL
THESE THINGS CONTRIBUTE
SIGNIFICANTLY. THE LAST RIDAY
GOVERNOR NEWSOM CAME TO FRESNO.
AND HE HIGHLIGHTED SB EIGHTY
FIVE IN ALL THE CONTENTS OF THE
BUDGET PROVISIONS. AND I THINK
YOU KNOW EVERYONE CAN CAN TAKE
DIFFERENT SIDES OR ANGLES ON
THIS ISSUE BUT NOBODY CAN
DISAGREE THIS IS NOT A
PRIORITY. AND I WANT TO COMMEND
GOVERNOR NEWSOM FROM COMING TO
FRESNO- TO DO IT TOO- VISITING
THE IMPACTED AREAS- AT TIMES
PRIOR SO HE HAS FIRST HAND
KNOWLEDGE AND UNDERSTANDING OF
WHAT IT'S LIKE TO LIVE IN A
MOUNTAIN COMMUNITY THAT'S BEEN
DEVASTATED. AND PROPERTIESHAVE
TO BE REBUILT NOT KNOWING IF
THAT'S POSSIBLE OR EVEN IF IT
IF INSURANCE MIGHT BE AVAILABLE.
WE KNOW THE CLIMATE IN THE
ECOLOGICAL CHANGES THAT ARE
OCCURRING. SO MUCH SO THAT MANY
OF US ARE ARE YOU IN THE
LEGISLATURE HAVE ASKED THE
GOVERNOR TO DECLARE A STATE OF
EMERGENCY ON WATER WE'RE IN
THOSE TYPE OF DIRE STRAITS. AND
SO WE'RE HOPEFUL THAT AS WE
LOOK AT THE ECOLOGICAL CHANGES
THAT ARE OCCURRING THAT WE HAVE
A COMMENSURATE POLITICAL AND
FINANCIAL RESPONSE ON HOW TO
DEAL WITH THEM SO WITH THAT
COLLEAGUES I WILL BE SUPPORTING
S. B. EIGHTY FIVE M. I'M PROUD
THAT THIS IS A STEP IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION. THANK YOU
SENATOR DOT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT BOB LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN OF THE SENATE I WANT
TO BRIEFLY COMMENT ON THIS
EARLY ACTION A WILDFIRE BUDGET
FIRST I WANT TO COMMEND THE BUT
ENTIRE BUDGET TEAM FOR THE
GREAT JOB THAT THEY DID ON THIS
IN PARTICULAR LIKE TO COMMEND
THE SENATORS FROM BALDWIN PARK
IN HEALDSBURG- WHO LED THE
SENATE WHILE FORMER. NO THREE.
TO DEVELOP A PACKAGE PROPOSAL
BUDGET PROPOSAL THAT IS LARGELY
REFLECTED IN THE PACKAGE WE ARE
TO VOTE ON. I ALSO WANT TO
THANK THE SENATOR FROM FREMONT
OUR CHAIR BUDGET SUB TO FOR HIS
SUBCOMMITTEE SWIFT ACTION TO
APPROVE THAT PACKAGE. BY ALL
ACCOUNTS WE ARE FACING A
DANGEROUS FIRE SEASON THE LARA
PROLONGED FIRE- SEASON DRY
WEATHER. QUICK ACTION IS THE
MANAGE IN TREAT THE VEGETATION
THERE ARE HIGHEST WILDFIRE
THREATS OWNS INCLUDING
PRESCRIBED BURNING IT TO
PROVIDE DEFENSIVE SPACE AND
FUEL BREAKS. IN CRITICAL AREAS.
ARE PARTICULARLY PLEASED WITH
THE FUNDING FOR WILDFIRE
PREVENTION IT FOR SELF GRANTS.
ARE COUNTIES IN FAR WISE FIRE
SAFE COUNCILS HAVE BEEN WORKING
TIRELESSLY TO READY PROJECTS
THAT WILL PROTECT COMMUNITIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. IT'S
IMPERATIVE THAT WE GET THE
RESOURCES INTO THEIR HEADS
EARLY WITHOUT DELAY I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A YES VOTE
ON S. B. EIGHTY FIVE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR STERN. THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT. THANK YOU
MEMBERS FOR THE DISCUSSION
TODAY- I TO RISE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS LEGISLATION IS A MEMBER
WHO'S BEEN THROUGH- OVER TEN
WILDFIRES IN. MY DISTRICT SINCE
COMING INTO OFFICE AND WHEN I
FIRST TOOK OFFICE- A WILDFIRE
THAT TOOK UP MY WHOLE HOME TOWN
INCLUDING MY HOME KNOWING WHAT
IT FEELS LIKE TO BE A VICTIM A
WILDFIRE- I WOULD APPRECIATE
WHAT. ARE SENATE BUDGET SUB
HERE IS DONE BY PUSHING THE
ENVELOPE HERE ARE CHAIRS THE
WILDFIRE WORKING GROUP THE
GOVERNOR. FOR SHOWING UP AND-
STEPPING THROUGH THOSE ASHES
WITH US WHEN WE LOST
EVERYTHING. THIS IMPORTANT STEP
FORWARD AND I WANT TO BUILD ON-
MIGHT MY COLLEAGUES FROM
FRESNO'S REMARKS ABOUT BEING.
COMMENSURATE WITH THE SCALE OF
THE CHALLENGE WE HEARD
TESTIMONY EARLIER THIS YEAR
THAT THE LIABILITY TO THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA FOR THE TWO
MILLION PEOPLE LIVING. DIRECTLY
IN THE WILD FIRE ZONES COULD BE
OVER A TRILLION DOLLARS. THAT'S
WITH A T. TODAY WERE PASSING A
MEASURE THAT WILL PUT FORWARD
ALMOST HALF A BILLION DOLLARS
AND IS THE PRO TEM IS RIGHTLY
POINTED OUT FOR EVERY DOLLAR WE
SPEND ON THESE EFFORTS WE SAVE
SIXTY SEVEN DOLLARS ON THE BACK
AND- SO WITH THIS ACT TODAY I
THINK WE'LL BE SAVING. THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA SOMEWHERE
AROUND THREE BILLION DOLLARS
OVER THE NEXT FEW YEARS WHICH
IS A HUGE HUGE COST SAVINGS NOT
JUST FINANCIALLY BUT FOR
PEOPLE'S LIVES. BUT I WANT TO I
WANT TO STATE TO YOU ALL THAT
THIS IS GOING TO. CAN CAN YOU
TO REQUIRE SUSTAINED INVESTMENT
AT A SCALE THAT I DON'T THINK
WE CAN QUITE IMAGINE AT THIS
POINT- A TRILLION DOLLAR
LIABILITY NOT JUST FOR
HOMEOWNERS LIVING. IN CANYONS
AND HILLSIDES IN RURAL AREAS
THAT THAT YOU MAY NOT
REPRESENT. BUT THE WILDFIRE
SMOKE IN THE IMPACT OF THESE
EVENTS ON PREMATURE BIRTHS ON
SEVERE ASTHMA. ON EXTREME
RESPIRATORY ILLNESS AND EVEN
NOW ACCORDING TO A NEW STUDY BY
STANFORD LAST MONTH. THE WILD
FIRES WE HAD LAST WINTER WILL
PERMANENTLY AFFECT THE GENETICS
OF NEWBORN BABIES BORN
EVERYWHERE THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA THAT WAS EXPOSED TO
WILDFIRE SMOKE THE MOST TOXIC
SORT. SO THIS IS NOT JUST A
WILDLAND URBAN INTERFACE ISSUE
THIS IS AN ISSUE FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS WHICH IS WHY THIS
MEASURE I BELIEVE IS SO
IMPORTANT HERE TODAY- BUT IT IS
JUST THE FIRST STEP TRULY. THE
TWENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS FOR
EXAMPLE FOR HOME HARDENING WILL
COVER ABOUT TWELVE THOUSAND
HOMES THAT'S LESS THAN 1% OF
THE TOTAL PROBLEM. SO WE HAVE
OUR WORK CUT OUT FOR US HERE
BUT- WE'RE STARTING TO HONE IN
ON THE ISSUE AND THE FACT THAT
WE'VE NOW REALIZED THAT
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA HAS UNIQUE
WILDFIRE THREATS. THAT AREN'T
CROWN FIRES OR FUEL DRIVEN
FIRES BUT WIND DRIVEN FIRES
WERE ONE SPARK CAN BURN A HOLE
COMMUNITY DOWN. IT IT'S ABOUT
VENTS AND EVEN GASKET IN THE
SIMPLE SMALL THINGS CALLING OUT
THE SANTA MONICA MOUNTAINS
CONSERVANCY IN THESE OTHER
LOCAL AND REGIONAL ENTITIES I
THINK WILL BE THE FUTURE OF
FIRE PREVENTION IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND FOR THAT REASON
I STAND IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR WHY
CULTURALLY. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT I TOO WOULD URGE-
THIS BODY TO AGREE A CONCUR IN
THE AMENDMENT CITY ASSEMBLY HAS
TAKEN TO. THE WILDFIRE- PACKAGE
THIS MEASURE IN FRONT OF US.
PARALLELS SIR REFLECT ALIGNS
WITH THE ACTION WAS TAKEN AND-
THE BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE- BACK
IN AROUND VALENTINE'S DAY WHERE
WE HAD FIVE HUNDRED SEVENTY
THREE MILLION DOLLARS THAT WAS
PUT FOR WILDFIRE PREVENTION
BECAUSE IT REFLECTS. THE VALUES
THAT THE MEMBERS OF THIS BODY
HAVE BEEN- TALKING ABOUT
ADVOCATING FOR TO DEAL WITH
MORE- NOT ONLY CLIMATE CHANGE
BUT WILDFIRE PREVENTION AND
RESILIENCY EFFORTS THAT WAS. A
QUARTER OF A BILLION DOLLARS
MORE THAN WHAT THE WHAT THE
GOVERNOR HAD HAD SET OUT SO I
LISTEN TO THEM MY COLLEAGUES
WHO HAVE SPOKEN AND IT'S
GRATIFYING. THAT WE'RE TAKING
THIS INITIAL STEP RIGHT NOW
EARLY ACTION BECAUSE THE BUDGET
BUDGET YEAR IS GOING TO INCLUDE
OTHERS SPENDING PROPOSALS NOT
INCLUDED IN THIS BACKPACK IS
BEFORE YOU I JUST WANT TO TOUCH
ON IT. IS THAT THERE IS THIRTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS AT THE
SUBCOMMITTEE A TAKEN FOR NEW
FIRE CREWS TO SIXTEEN FIRE
CREWS THE ADMINISTRATION FOUND
THE MONEY IN THE REGULAR BUDGET
AND THOSE. FOLKS ARE ALREADY
BEING HIRED WORK IS GOING ON IN
THE IN THE PREVENTION FIELD SO
THAT'S THERE. I KNOW A LOT OF
FOLKS THAT ARE HERE ARE
CONCERNS ABOUT COOLING CENTERS
BECAUSE YOU'RE- A COMMUNITIES
HAVE BEEN HIT. WHEN THE FIRES
TO OCCUR OCCUR AND THAT'S MORE
APPROPRIATELY IN THE EMERGENCY
RESPONSE AND- AND AT WHICH WILL
BE PART OF THE REGULAR- BUDGET.
D. AS MY COLLEAGUES FROM
THOUSAND OAKS IS NOT ONLY.
CELEBRATING HIS BIRTHDAY- BUT
HIGHLIGHTED THAT THIS IS MULTI
DIMENSIONAL APPROACH THAT- THIS
ACTION TAKES WHERE WE'RE
LOOKING AT WILD PLANTS YES WE
HAVE FOR US BUT WE ALSO HAVE
CHAPARRAL WE ALSO HAVE.
WOODLANDS THAT WE'RE DOING AND-
AS MEMBERS OF THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE HEARD EARLIER TODAY
THIS IS REALLY AN INVESTMENT
BOTH PUBLICLY AND PRIVATELY
THERE IS LOTS AND LOTS AND LOTS
OF MONEY HERE FOR. FIRE SAFE
COUNCILS FOR COUNTIES FOR THE-
BAND BAND GRANT PROGRAMS AT THE
CAL FIRE WILL- WILL PUT OUT. IT
COVERS A MULTIPLE OF SCALES
ALSO WERE. ISSUED AS WE TALK
ABOUT. THE GUY ORIGINAL HAD.
FORTY MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
HEALTHY FOREST PROGRAMS AND
WE'VE UP THAT BY A HUNDRED
DOLLARS THAT IS ALL AVAILABLE
FOR LOCAL- OF FOLKS TO DO
PRESCRIBED BURNS TO DO FUEL
TREATMENT REDUCTIONS TO DO.
REFORESTED IS ASIAN TO BIOMASS-
IT'S A TEMPLATE. BUT AS WE'VE
HEARD. WE SHOULD PROBABLY BE
SPENDING. TWICE AS MUCH MONEY
THAN THIS ON A YEARLY BASIS ON
PREVENTION WERE OUR BUDGET FOR
THE LAST THREE YEARS HAS BEEN
ABOUT TWO POINT TWO BILLION AND
SUPPRESSION AND THAT'S
IMPORTANT WHEN THE FIRE
STARPOINT WE- AS A BUDGETEERS
INDICATE ONE DOLLAR INVENSYS
INVENTED IN PREVENTION. IS
WORTH- SIX OR SEVEN DOLLARS-
ECONOMICALLY FOR THE FOR THAT
SO- I ENCOURAGE FOLKS TO SHARE
WITH THEIR LOCAL- OUR COUNCIL'S
FIRE COUNCILS IN- THE- COUNTY
SUPERVISORS THESE ARE. LARGE
LANDSCAPES PROJECTS DOWN TO
INDIVIDUAL HOME HARDENING IS A
LITTLE BIT OF SOMETHING FOR
EVERYBODY AND IT PROVIDES A
TEMPLATE FOR PROGRAMS THAT- WE
LOOK FOR TO FUNDING IN THE
FUTURE I WILL POINT OUT ONE OF
THE SENATE PRIORITIES- WHAT IS
THE- THE FACT CONSERVANCIES
THAT WILL PUT MONEY DIRECTLY IN
THE HANDS OF THE CONSERVANCY
SET WORK WITH PARTNERS WITH CAL
FIRE THE SANTA MONICA.
MOUNTAINS CONSERVANCY SAN DIEGO
RIVER CONSERVANCY A STATE
COASTAL CONSERVANCY IN CAN'T
SAN GABRIEL AND LOWER LOS
ANGELES CONSERVANCY I
APPRECIATE ALL THE INPUT FROM
THE WORKING. GROUP ON THIS
MATTER TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT
THAT THOSE FOLKS ARE. FUNDED
AND FINALLY OF MY COLLEAGUES
WHO HAVE UP FROM THE EIGHTH
SENATE DISTRICT THE SIERRA.
NEVADA CONSERVANCY HAS OVER A
HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE PROJECTS
THAT ARE READY AND THIS THIS
TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS THAT'S
INCLUDED IN THIS PROJECT IS
SIMPLY A DOWN PAYMENT BECAUSE
THEY HAVE SO MANY PROJECTS AND
THEY'RE GOING TO BE THAT. THE
LEADER- OR ONE OF THE LEADERS
IN IN THE STATE AS FAR SHOWING
US HOW WE CAN TREAT THE FORESTS
AND CHANGE THE LANDSCAPE TO
MAKE IT MORE RESILIENT AND
ENJOYABLE FOR ALL- CALIFORNIANS
IN WITH THAT. I WOULD URGE AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR
ATTARDO. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
I RISE IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
EIGHTY FIVE. YOU KNOW LAST YEAR
I GOT TO WITNESS A FIRST HAND
OF. THIS SEVERE IMPACTS THAT
FIRES THE CALLS ON ON THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA I KNOW
THAT. IT FIRES- ARE NOT
NECESSARILY ASSOCIATED TO THIS
YEAR OF WHAT THAT WHAT THE
CENTRAL VALLEY BUT- YEAH LAST
YEAR I GOT TO SEE THIS FOR HAD
FIRSTHAND THE IMPACT OF THE
FIRE SEASON AND THE DAMAGE THAT
IT THAT IT DOES TO PEOPLE. AND-
I KNOW THAT THERE IS A LOT MORE
THAT THAT NEEDS TO BE DONE THAT
TOO. TO RESTORE THE SOUL OF THE
PEOPLE THAT LOST. THEIR THEY'RE
SOLD LAST YEAR AND BEFORE IN
PREVIOUS YEARS BECAUSE OF THESE
FIRES. SO JUST WANT TO. YOU
KNOW STAND UP AS WELL AND JUST.
YOU KNOW MAKE A RECOMMITMENT
THERE TO THE PEOPLE THAT. LOST
SO MUCH- AND ALSO RE EMPHASIZED
THAT WE NEED TO DO MUCH MORE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM. SENIOR NO ADDITIONAL
MIKE'S SENATOR SKINNER WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS THANK YOU
FOR YOUR GOOD COMMENTS AND YES
I THINK THAT AS THE FLOOR
REMARKS HAVE INDICATED THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT IS NEEDED AND
IT'S NEEDED NOW AND IT'S
IMPORTANT TO ACT SO THAT WE CAN
GET THIS MONEY INTO THE HANDS
OF CALIFORNIA- OF OUR FIRE
SAFETY COUNCILS OF OUR
CONSERVANCIES. OF THE
CONSERVATION CORPS AND ALL THE
OTHERS WHO ARE GOING TO DO THE
GOOD AND IMPORTANT WORK TO HELP
US. REDUCE THE IMPACT OF
WILDFIRES AND HOPEFULLY REDUCE
EVEN THEIR OCCURRENCE AND WITH
THAT I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN HI
ARCHULETA HI ATKINS AYE BATES I
BAKER. FIVE PORGES FIVE
BRADFORD BYE BYE CABALLERO FIVE
CORTESE HI DALLY. FIVE DODD. HI
TERRAZZO FIVE EGGMAN HI GLAZER
FIVE GONZALEZ I GROWTH. HI
HERTZBERG. HI WITH SO. HI HER
TADO BY JONES HI KAMLAGER HI
LAYERED. HI LEYVA HI LIMON.
MCGUIRE HI MELENDEZ HI MEN HI
NEWMAN. HI NIELSEN HI A SHOW OF
BOTH HI PAM HI PORTANTINO HI
ROTH. HI RUBIO HI SKINNER. HI
STERN HI I'M BURKE ALL RIGHT HI
WHAT KASKY. HI WIENER HI WILK
HI. MEMBERS ALL EYES NINE A
NOSE ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SPARKING KURT.
IS NOW MOVING BACK TO HIM
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS NOW IS
THE TIME FOR JOURN AND MEMORIES
WE HAVE THREE. SENATOR NUMBER
OF ARE YOU PREPARED. YEAH.
THE
NUMBER WHEN YOU'RE READY. THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT IN COLLEAGUES.
IT IS MY SAID HONOR AND
PRIVILEGE TO PASS THAT WE
ADJOURN. IN MEMORY RECOGNITION
OF MATTHEW FAR YES A THIRD
GRADER AT HOOVER ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL IN SANTA ANA. MATTHEW
LOVE BASKETBALL AND SOCCER HE
WAS A FREQUENT PARTICIPANT
CUSTOM YMCA. AT HOME WE LOVE TO
PLAY FORTNITE ON HIS X. BOX AND
PLAYING TAG AND HIDE AND GO
SEEK WITH HIS DOG RUBY. I
TALKED TO MATTHEW'S FATHER
RAPHAEL IN HIS IN HIS GODFATHER.
IS WELL- RAPHAEL DESCRIBE
MATTHEW IS ONLY SON HIS ONLY
CHILD THIS IS LIGHT HIS MOTOR
HIS ENGINE. HE WAS A KID WITH
BIG DREAMS WHEN HE GREW UP HE
TOLD IS THERE ANYONE TO BE AN
ASTRONAUT OR FIGHTER. HE WAS
SENSITIVE AND CARED FOR HIS
FAMILY. MATTHEW ALONG WITH HIS
SISTER GENEVIEVE AND UNCLE
LOUISE WERE VICTIMS OF THE
ORANGE MASS SHOOTING LAST
WEDNESDAY. MATTHEW'S MOTHER
BLANCA CONTINUES TO FIGHT FOR
LIFE SHE WAS FOUND. OUT
COVERING HER. NOW TO SEIZE SON.
THE INCIDENT WAS HORRIFYING AND
SHOCKING LOSS TO OUR COMMUNITY
THANK YOU PAYING FOR. ALL THOSE
WHO LOST THOSE RELATIVES AND
FOR OUR COMMUNITY- WILL MISS
MATTHEW ARE HIS MOTHER. HIS
BROTHER IN HIS GODFATHER WE
KEEP THEM IN OUR MEMORY AND OUR
PRAYERS AS WE JOURNEY IN THEIR
MEMORY I BELIEVE- SENATOR
NEWMAN AND SENATOR MEN ALSO-
HAVE A GERMAN MEMORIES IN
CONNECTION WITH THIS TRAGIC
EVENT SENATE YES CENTER NEWMAN
TOOK NEXT SYNONYM. WELL IF WERE
WAITING CENTER MAN IF YOU'RE
PREPARED. MIKE'S NOT ONTO LET'S
GET CENTER MEN'S MIKE. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR OF MEMBERS THE
THREE OF US RISE TODAY IN
MEMORY OF FOR PEOPLE
CONSTITUENTS OF OURS IN ORANGE
COUNTY WHOSE LIVES WERE TAKEN
FROM US FAR TOO SOON. AS WE'VE
ALL READ ABOUT ON THE EVENING
OF MARCH THIRTY FIRST A
WEDNESDAY A MASS SHOOTING TOOK
PLACE IN THE CITY OF ORANGE IN
THE THIRTY SEVEN SENATE
DISTRICT. AND STOLE FROM US THE
LIVES OF LOUIS STOVE ARE. HIS
DAUGHTER GENEVIEVE RATE GOES
UP. HER NINE YEAR OLD BROTHER
MATTHEW SERIOUS IN THEIR CO
WORKER LETICIA SO LEASE- SPENT.
THE MAN WHO. PERPETRATED THIS
MASS SHOOTING. I HIS MOTIVES
WERE UNKNOWN BUT HE WITH MALICE
AFORETHOUGHT LOCKED THE GATES
THE COURTYARD AND
SYSTEMATICALLY SHOT DOWN THESE
PEOPLE. IT'S ABSOLUTELY
HEARTBREAKING TO HEAR ABOUT
THIS MASS SHOOTING WITH
MULTIPLE LIVES INCLUDING A
CHILD. WERE TAKEN FROM US TOO
SOON IN ORANGE COUNTY IN MY
SENATE-DISTRICT AND FOR ME THIS
IS VERY PERSONAL. IT FOR A LOT
OF REASONS BUT I WAS JUST A FEW
MILES AWAY WHEN THE SHOOTING
TOOK PLACE I WAS TAKING MY
DAUGHTER TO A DOCTOR'S
APPOINTMENT. AND WHEN I GOT
HOME AND READ ABOUT THISAND
HAD HEARD ABOUT THIS TRAGIC
NEWS. THOUGHT REPEATEDLY
CROSSED MY MIND THAT IF WE HAD
JUST BEEN IN A DIFFERENT PLACE
AND DIFFERENT TIME THAT WE TOO
COULD HAVE BEEN VICTIMS OF THIS
MASS SHOOTING. AND SO LUIS
TOVAR I CONSIDER MINE REMINDS
ME OF MYSELF IN SO MANY WAYS
MUCH COOLER VERSION OF MYSELF-
BUT HE SIXTY YEARS OLD AN
ORANGE COUNTY NATIVE. A FAMILY
MAN WITH FIVE CHILDREN AND SIX
GRANDCHILDREN. A GRADUATE OF
ANAHEIM HIGH SCHOOL WHERE HE
WAS NAMED SENIOR PROM KING.
LEWIS EARNED HIS BACHELOR'S
DEGREE AND MASTER'S DEGREE IN
BUSINESS ADMINISTRATION AND
FINANCE FROM CAL STATE
FULLERTON. HE TALKED ABOUT
MAYBE ONE DAY GOING TO LAW
SCHOOL AND GETTING A JURIS
DOCTORATE. BUT INSTEAD IN THE
MEANTIME HE HAD BEEN WORKING AT
UNIFIED HOMES IN ORANGE COUNTY
A COMPANY HE HAD FOUNDED AS A
FAMILY BUSINESS. TO TRY TO HELP
PEOPLE BREAK INTO THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING MARKET
THROUGH SALES AND MANUFACTURED
AND MOBILE HOMES. HE WILL BE
DEEPLY MISSED BY HIS FAMILY WHO
LOVED HIM DEARLY AND THE
COMMUNITY WHICH HE SERVED IN
OUR THIRTY SEVEN STATE SENATE
DISTRICTS. I'M LEARN MORE WITH
THE SENATE VICTIMS FAMILIES AND
LOVED ONES AND I PRAY FOR THEIR
SALAS BUT I WANT TO EMPHASIZE A
MESSAGE THAT WE HAVE ALL STATE
A LOT. BUT NEED TO CONTINUE
SAYING THOUGHTS AND PRAYERS ARE
NOT ENOUGH. JUST HOURS AGO.
NEWS WAS BREAKING ANOTHER MASS
SHOOTING IN KNOXVILLE TENNESSEE
A SCHOOL SHOOTING. WE DON'T
KNOW THE NUMBER OF VICTIMS WE
DON'T KNOW WHAT'S GOING ON
THERE BUT- AS WE ARE RECOVERING
FROM COLD AND WE ARE FACING A
NEW EPIDEMIC OF MASS SHOOTINGS
AND QUIETLY LAST YEAR IT WAS
THE DEADLIEST. GUN VIOLENCE
YEAR IN DECADES. BUT NOW WE'RE
STARTING TO SEE THAT GUN
VIOLENCE CREEP OUT OF
HOUSEHOLDS. OUT OF DOMESTIC
RELATIONSHIPS AND INTO THE
PUBLIC SPHERE AGAIN AS WE OPEN
UP. AND WE ARE ONCE AGAIN PUT
IN A POSITION WHERE ANYONE OF
US AT ANY TIME CAN BE SEEN. HAS
TO WORRY ABOUT BEING A VICTIM
OF. GUN VIOLENCE FOR ANY
REASON. THE UNITED STATES HAS A
GUN VIOLENCE HOMICIDE RATE THAT
IS TWENTY FIVE TIMES HIGHER
THAN ANY OTHER FIRST WILL
COUNTRY. WE CANNOT ACCEPT THIS
AS NORMAL WE CANNOT ACCEPT THE
STATUS QUO WE MUST AS ELECTED
OFFICIALS CONTINUE TO WORK TO
TRY TO REDUCE GUN VIOLENCE.
THAT IS WHAT WE HAVE TO DO TO
HONOR THESE VICTIMS. SO I ASK
YOU. TO GIVE YOUR THOUGHTS AND
PRAYERS BUT ALSO TO LEND TO US
YOUR ACTION YOUR VOTES. TO TRY
TO MAKE SURE THAT THIS STOPS
HAPPENING IN OUR SOCIETY. THANK
YOU SENATOR NEWMAN. THANK YOU
MR PRESIDENT DIED I JOIN MY
COLLEAGUES IN ASSURING MEMORY
OF THE VICTIMS OF THIS
SENSELESS CRIME TWO OF WHOM
WERE CONSTITUENTS OF MY
DISTRICT THE TISSUE SO LEASE
GOOSE MON OR LADY AS SHE WAS
LOVELY NO BY THOSE CLOSE TO HER
WAS TRAGICALLY TAKEN FROM US ON
MARCH THIRTY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY ONE IN THE MASS SHOOTING
THAT TOOK PLACE IN ORANGE. BORN
IN MEXICO THE TISSUE IMMIGRATED
TO THE UNITED STATES WITH HER
FAMILY WHEN SHE WAS YOUNG AND
RAPIDLY PUT DOWN ROOTS IN
ORANGE COUNTY EARLY ON SHE SET
HER SIGHTS ON A BETTER LIFE
HERE IN AMERICA AND SPENT HER
DAYS WORKING TOWARDS. THE
TISSUE BECAME A REAL ESTATE
AGENT AND INTO TWO THOUSAND SIX
SHE JOINED UNIFIED HOMES WHERE
CLOSE FRIEND LOUISE TWELVE R.
WHO ALSO DIED IN THE SHOOTING
WITH THE LONGTIME OWNER
PETITION TOOK IMMENSE PRIDE IN
HER PROFESSION AND REVELED IN
THE KNOWLEDGE THAT THROUGH HER
WORK SHE COULD PUT FAMILIES
FROM ALL WALKS OF LIFE INTO NEW
HOMES. BUT AS MUCH PRIDE AS SHE
TOOK IN HER WORK NOTHING COULD
COMPARE TO THE LOVE AND PRIDE
THE TWO SHE HAD FOR HER FOUR
CHILDREN SHE WAS THE PROUD
MOTHER DENISE JORDY ANGIE AND
ALEXIS SHE MADE SURE TO TELL
YOUR CHILDREN HOW MUCH YOU LOVE
THEM EVERY CHANCE SHE COULD.
WHEN ASKED. ABOUT THEIR VERY
DEEP AND LOVING BY WITH THEIR
MOTHER. PETITIONS FOR CHILDREN
SAID SHE LOVED US
UNCONDITIONALLY. AND WE FELT
THAT WE KNEW SHE LOVED US MORE
THAN ANYTHING BECAUSE SHE WOULD
REMIND US CONSTANTLY. SHE
TAUGHT THE FOUR OF US TO ALWAYS
BE THERE FOR EACH OTHER. AND TO
NEVER LEAVE EACH OTHER'S SIDES.
SHE WAS HER BEST FRIEND. AND
EVERYTHING SHE DID WAS FOR US.
TO SHOW LOVE TO DANCE AND HER
INFECTIOUS POSITIVITY PERMITTED
ANY ROOM SHE ENTERED. HER
OPTIMISM IN APPRECIATION FOR
LIFE FOR BEST EXEMPLIFIED BY A
POST. SHE MADE ON OUR FACEBOOK
PAGE. THE MORNING OF THE DAY
SHE WAS KILLED. HOW TIME FLIES
BUT THANK GOD WITH HEALTH AND
WORK GOOD MORNING. FRIENDS AND
FAMILY. LETITIA LIKE SO MANY OF
US WAS EAGERLY PREPARING FOR
THE OVERLAP OF THE COMING OF
SPRING. AND THE RETURN OF
NORMALCY IN THE WAKE OF THE
PANDEMIC. SHE WAS HAPPY MAKING
ARRANGEMENTS FOR THEIR FAMILY
TO GET VACCINATED TO PLAN-FAMILY TRIPS. SHE SPOKE
LONGINGLY AND OPTIMISTICALLY OF
ALL THE GREAT THINGS AWAITING
THEIR FAMILY. FESTIVE FAMILY
GATHERINGS LEISURELY OUTINGS.
IN A IN A SENSE ONCE AGAIN OF
PEACE AND FAMILIARITY. LIKE ALL
THOSE WHOSE LIVES WERE LOST IN
SPIEGEL ACTS OF VIOLENCE. THE
TEACHER LEFT THIS EARTH FAR TOO
SOON AT FIFTY EIGHT YEARS OLD.
THIS UNSPEAKABLE TRAGEDY IS
LETTER FOR CHILDREN. AND
MEMBERS OF OUR COMMUNITY WITH A
VOID. THAT CAN NEVER BE FILLED.
I RISE AS WELL TODAY TO JOIN IN
MEMORY OF GENEVIEVE RATE GOES
UP. WHO ALONG WITH HER FATHER
LUIZ ALONSO TOWBAR. WAS AMONG
THE VICTIMS OF THE SHOOTING
THAT TOOK PLACE ON THAT DAY.
MARCH THIRTY FIRST. BORN IN
ANAHEIM ON JUNE FOURTH NINETEEN
NINETY TWO GENEVIEVE GREW UP
PLANTED FIRMLY IN OUR LOCAL
COMMUNITY AND ATTENDED PUBLIC
SCHOOLS IN THE AREA. SHE
GRADUATED FROM ANAHEIM HIGH
SCHOOL AND ATTENDED FULLERTON
COLLEGE WHERE SHE FOCUSED HER
STUDIES AND BUSINESS
ADMINISTRATION. WITH PLANS TO
JOIN THE FAMILY REAL ESTATE
BUSINESS. LITTLE BIT GENEVIEVE
NO THAT WHILE TAKING CLASSES
THERE SHE WOULD ALSO MEET HER
FUTURE HUSBAND ARE MONDO. THE
COUPLE'S ATTRACTION WAS
IMMEDIATE AND IT WAS OUR MARKET
WAS GENEVIEVE DESPITE HER
NORMAL SHYNESS. WHO TOOK THE
INITIATIVE AND TOGETHER SHE AND
OUR MONDO. BUILT A VIBRANT LIFE
AND A LOVING HOME TO INCLUDE
THEIR TWO LOVING CHILDREN.
NATHANIEL AND UNDRESS. WHEN
GENEVIEVE JOIN UNIFIED HOMES
THE FAMILY'S REAL ESTATE
BUSINESS SHE BROUGHT OUR MONDO
ALONG WITH HER THEY TRULY
BALANCE EACH OTHER IN BOTH WORK
AND LIFE THAT UNITED HOMES.
GENEVIEVE WORKED AS A
TRANSACTION MANAGER. AT OUR
MONDO WORKED AS A CONSTRUCTION
MANAGER AT HOME CHEN OF THE
POOR THE ENTIRETY OF HER LOVE.
INTO OUR FAMILY OUR MONDO
DESCRIBED HIS WIFE. IS THE
KINDEST PERSON HE KNEW. AND A
SOURCE OF INFINITE CARE AND
THOUGHTFULNESS OTHERS CLOSE TO
HER DESCRIBED HER SIMPLY AS
SUNSHINE ON A CLOUDY DAY IT IS
FOR AN INDIVIDUAL SUCH KINDNESS
WHOSE OPTIMISM JOY SHOWN
THROUGH ANY HARDSHIP OR
ADVERSITY FOR WHOM WE NOW
GRIEVE. THESE MURDERS A
TRAGEDIES THAT CANNOT BE PUT
INTO WORDS NO FAMILY NO PARENT
AND NO CHILD SHOULD HAVE TO
ENDURE THE LOSS THAT ARMANDO
NATHANIEL AND UNDRESS ARE
CURRENTLY EXPERIENCING OUR
HEARTS GO OUT TO THE FAMILIES
OF THE TEACHER. AND GENEVIEVE.
AND THOSE TOUCHED BY YOUR
SPIRIT I ASKED MY COLLEAGUES TO
JOIN ME AS WE TURN IN HER
MEMORY TODAY. THANK YOU
SENATORS AND WE DO ASK THAT ALL
FOUR NAMES BE BROUGHT FOR SO WE
CAN PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED HIM
IN OUR HEARTS GO OUT TO. ALL
FOR FAMILIES IN A SENSELESS
TRAGEDY. SPEAKS TO THE NEED FOR
REAL GUN REFORM IN THIS COUNTRY.
NEXT UP SENATOR BORDERS. IF I
MAY- I WOULD LIKE TO MAKE A
COMMENT ON GUBERNATORIAL
APPOINTMENT THAT WAS PASSED
EARLIER TODAY WITH YOUR
PERMISSION. UNDER PRIVILEGES ON
THE FLOOR THANK YOU KINDLY YES.
COLLEAGUES IF I MAY I'D LIKE TO
MAKE A BRIEF COMMENT ON THE
APPOINTMENT OF THE ANY EAGER TO
THE TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION.
A FOURTH GENERATION PRESIDENT
MISSY- GRADUATED FROM
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
FRESNO AND EARNED HER JD FROM
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA.
DAVIS SCHOOL OF LAW. AS
PRESIDENT AND CEO OF THE FRESNO
COUNTY ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
CORPORATION. SHE HAS DONE. A
FANTASTIC JOB OF ATTRACTING
INVESTMENT TO THE GREATER
FRESNO AREA. INDUSTRY
RECRUITMENT AND RETENTION. RULE
BUSINESS EXPANSION AND PUBLIC
POLICY INITIATIVES AS PART OF
THE REGION'S VISION TO CREATE
LONG TERM ECONOMIC RESILIENCY.
MISS EAGER HAS A LONGSTANDING
HISTORY OF LEADERSHIP AND
SERVICE TO OUR COMMUNITY I CAN
ATTEST TO THAT ON THE FIRST.
HAND BASIS HAVING WORKED WITH
HER IN MY FORMER CAPACITIES AS
A FRESNO CITY COUNCILMAN AND OF
COURSE ON THE INFERSOF COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS.
COLLEAGUES I WANNA THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME AND I APPRECIATE
YOUR APPOINTMENT OF LEE AND
EAGER TO THE TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
AERATE IF THERE'S NO OTHER
BUSINESS SENATOR HERTZBERG THE
DALLAS IS CLEAR. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR PRESIDENT THE NEXT. THE
NEXT FLOOR SESSIONS UNDER JONES
THE NEXT FLOOR SESSION
SCHEDULED FOR THURSDAY APRIL
FIFTEENTH AT NINE AM OF LOT OF
WORK TO DO BETWEEN NOW AND THEN
THANK YOU EVERYONE LOOK FOR
SENIOR THAT. MEMBERS THE SENATE
WILL BE ADJOURNED. WE WILL
RECONVENE ON THURSDAY AT NINE
AM. THE STATE SENATE STAND
ADJOURNED.